If we did end up in our bags was not
to put a massive amount of effort into
getting up, just play garden
and stay safe because you know,
the next round starts on the feet and
tried to do damage there but it's still
tiring and I, I, you know, kind
of gets a hard time about as a,
Yvette is cardio all the time,
but who is,
could be faced that didn't look like
that after two rounds and winter I quit.
Yeah. Yeah. I mean I was super impressed.
Ally Quinta in that fight.
It especially considering he came
into that fight looking for a third,
a three round fight. I mean that
was what he was trained for, right?
He was trained for a three round fight
and it changes up and all of a sudden
he's in a five round fight for
the title. Fucking crazy. Yeah.
Crazy set of circumstances.
But it almost makes you wonder,
and this is maybe you could speak to
this better than anybody, how much,
how much is too much and in regard
to training for a fight like this,
like maybe training for a three round
fight is the way to go when you have to
fight a five round fight so
you're not so fucking beat up.
By the time you get to the fight, if you
already know how to fight five rounds,
you've already done it.
If you're a guy like Conor was just
got so much experience in the game,
it might be that it's like there's a
point of diminishing returns in terms of
your strength and conditioning
and that guys just go too far,
pushed too hard and just don't
have it when it comes to, I mean,
how many times have you seen a fighter
be overtrained when they fight?
Very often. Definitely. You know, they've,
they've given their best rounds and the
gym and it's very difficult as well.
And those last two weeks,
because anxiety is starting to grow.
So you want to train harder,
you'd want to get one more aspiring and
you want to know because the flight's
coming.
And so it's almost like when you were
back in school and you were cramming for
an exam, the exam's tomorrow, I'm going
to stay up all night studying. You know,
it actually got me through
college, so I worked so much. But,
but in fighting we got to do, we've got
to do the opposite. We don't have it.
We've got to have a
solid taper off period.
And that is hard when you're dealing with
a 20 something year old man and he's,
he's dealing with what's,
what's coming around the corner.
So, but you know, that's,
that's the trainer's job. You know. How
much did he taper off for this fight? Uh,
same as usual.
We have about a two week taper off period
where we start bringing it down. Um,
he did that. He did actually spar
even after that. Um, you know, we're,
we were working very hard for this
fight and the limit, you know,
somewhat limited period
of time. Um, so we did,
didn't taper off quite the
way we would normally do,
but roughly two weeks if
you want to do a rematch
and the UFC did grant agreement,
this is obviously dependent upon how
the Nevada state athletic commission
handles the legal ramifications of him
jumping out of the cage, attacking Dylan,
Dan as the subsequent brawl,
the chaos that ensued visas.
You mean you're,
you're dealing with a lot of legal shit,
this fight that could hold things
up. I mean, they held both guys
as person is correct. Uh, well the
held a Habib's Conor got his. Okay.
Conor goes press.
So he gets his first and be,
I mean,
who the fuck knows what's going to happen
with him, you know, and uh, yeah, I,
I hope they're, they're lenient on them
and I'm not just so we can get a rematch.
I mean, I love watching him
fight first. That, and I can,
I can stretch myself to understand his
reaction. I can stretch myself to under,
I can't stretch myself to understand the
order guys' reactions on what they did
for him. He jumped over the
cage and he jumps on. It's,
it's not the end of the horse. The guy
that jumped in there was wearing red.
Who punched on her. Yeah. I'm not sure.
I think that's the Xbox and coach,
but I'm guessing he's a fighter.
He fights for the UFC, uh,
into red was done not an old, he wasn't
older. He actually worked with them. Oh,
okay. You, there you go. Who
is he? I don't know his name.
Either. Islam or son. Yeah. Yeah.
It was either his Llama style.
I don't think it was either one of those
guys. Like I know he's laughing guy.
He was,
you know,
he hit done and a guy in a suit
that heritage is Russian manager.
He hit Dylan either way. Um, but actually
indicates when your mind is went in and,
and hit him from behind. Yeah. You
know, I can't, I can't understand that.
Like I said, for, for, for Habib, I didn't
think it was, you know, it was, it's just,
it's almost, it's such a foolish thing
to do. [inaudible] to date already. One,
I know that Dylan was talking shit and
he was angry but like actually didn't say
anything because I heard a
few people signed up. Now I
was standing beside Dylan.
I didn't see what he did but I could hear.
So he didn't say anything
now and I watched the back.
I see any kind of beckoned them on, you
know, just stupid end the fight stuff.
But I didn't think it justified that
level of response then maybe there was
something else in the lead up.
You know,
probably dealing is a bit
of a troll online. So uh,
there was probably a bit of a build up of
voter stuff. But um, yeah, like I said,
it wasn't that big a deal to me. What have
you did? Yeah, just really wasn't, well,
there's two ways of looking at it
in terms of like the trash
talking and one way is that man,
does that sell a fight? I mean
it sells a fight. Me Connors,
one of the best ever at, if not the best
ever at a talking shit to opponents,
getting them riled up and me.
It is the reason why Josie,
although lost his composure and came
charging faith first at Conner. I mean,
you gotta think emotions play a big
part of that. It ramps up your stress.
It ramps up the fighters, a anxiety,
anticipation and the ramps up,
the pressure on them to win and to,
and this emotion that they're
fighting with fucks up their judgment.
It just does. And it's a major
tool that taner that Connor uses.
And,
but on the other hand,
we'll say,
well,
I'd like when fighters are respectful
and this is one of the things that could
be saying this, this, this. Uh,
sports should be about respect.
You shouldn't be talking about someone's
family shouldn't be talking about
someone's religion. You shouldn't
be talking about someone's country.
But you know,
on the other hand,
that's one of the reasons why Conor is so
fucking huge. It's not just as results,
it's all the other things
that come along with it.
Is the excitement that he a shit talking
though. Who the fuck is that guy?
Like that kind of shit.
That's a big part of who he is.
It's a part of who he is
as this cultural icon.
I mean it's one of the
reasons why people love them.
I mean they don't just love
his ability inside the octagon,
which is quite substantial
that they loved the swagger.
They love when he comes in with rubber
arms and, and struts around the cage.
They love all that shit.
It's like when is too far? And that
is the question. When is too far.
Yeah. Um, yeah, you know, Connor
is a real ad divider. You know,
if some people will love
it and some people hate it,
I'm not really that interested
in people's opinions on things.
I'm just interested in what is
and what is that sells fights.
There's a reason he's the highest
paid guy. Um, so if that is what is,
and that's just natural for him to do as
well. It's not an act. It's not, you know,
when he's sparring, I am an art. Them are
best of friends on every single sparity.
She's talking to her,
your shit today. You know,
you know what I'm forum today
and they're gonna, you know,
people listen to them like they hate each
other and then speak smiles at the end
of it. It's just part of the game
for him. It's probably enjoys it.
It's a bit of fun. This one was dark
or you know, as, as, as Dana said,
it definitely was,
but it's just part of who he is.
I don't really involve myself in it.
I tried to stay outside of that and
then just focus on the task at hand.
Ever get cringey for you because
you are a very respectful guy. Yeah.
I mean it's absolutely not my personality.
It's absolutely not my personality.
But again, I don't find my own
opinions on things. Very interesting.
I'm only interested in,
um, what is, you know,
there's a fact that he does this
and it's got an, the results he has.
Okay. Well, I guess that's what he
does. It's not how I am. Right. I mean,
you look at the two biggest
names in combat sports,
Floyd Mayweather and Conor
McGregor and they both do it. Yeah.
My favorite fighter back in
the day was fate or, and it,
there was a non that barely said anything
and the purest if you want to say
loved him, but he was also fighting
mostly in Japan. It's different vibe.
It's a different culture than here.
Um, you know, you could beat that guy.
And I almost have the two extremes I've
got to Nelson who you never hear a blip
out of. Yes. And then I have Connor who
was, you know, the other end of the scale.
And um, you know, you can only be true
to yourself, but at I look at their,
their,
you know,
their followings and their sponsorship
deals and their fight purses and stuff
and it's obvious which one is doing
better. You know, if, if, if the, if the,
if we can agree on the object, the prize
fighting is to make money and that's it.
The object of martial arts
I think is very different,
but the object of prize fighting
and don't ever lose sight of that.
As soon as I hear a fighter saying
it's for somewhere where reason,
I'll try to make them retire as quick
as possible because not being smart,
you know, you're, you're taking
damage for money and keep,
keep that in mind no matter
what your choices are.
Do you have guys in the gym that you see
that sort of mimic Connor? Oh, of course.
Of course. Yeah. You're, you're,
you're dealing with teenagers and, and,
and twenties and that's, you
know, I look back at myself,
it's a hugely impressionable,
impressionable period
of your life. You're,
you're looking,
you know,
we see young men almost try
out different personalities,
you know, and he was such a strong
personality in the gym. Definitely. I can,
I can spot the 18 year old walking in
with a man bun and the zoo telling me he's
going to be the next year.
I probably wouldn't be the same idea.
It's not different. But I true, again,
months and years of conversations,
you know,
not telling them what to do with
conversations. I sort of say, this is,
we've completely natural thing to do,
but start to find your own
voice and find your own way.
And if that's who you are, you enjoy
that side, but we'll run with it.
If it's not who you were. Even that the
fans will see true or very quick as well.
You know,
the fans can see when someone is genuinely
doing something and doing it as, as,
as an act.